[Music]
hello I'm pablo carlier partner
engineer at google cloud today we are going to take
our first steps with
machine learning or more in learning
thanks to google cloud auto ml at google
cloud we want to bring the benefits of
artificial intelligence to
everyone to  this we are
constantly researching to advance the state
of the art of technology by applying
these advances to new products and
fields and developing tools that
unlock their potential to millions of
developers through a simple
pib
so far we have packaged many of
these machine learning capabilities in
numerous pre-trained services with
generic data that range
from image or video recognition to
speech synthesis or transcription to text
to natural language analysis
translation and others
each of these apis has
very advanced functionalities that
help solve many use cases
but how  handle those cases where we would
need  having these capabilities
adjusted to our own data we
present auto ml a new technology
from google that automates the creation
of machine learning models from the pre-
processing of data to its
update, passing through the design of the
model, the adjustment of the parameters, the
evaluation and other tasks  very
specialized that until now were
only within the reach of a few
with auto ml we open up to thousands of experts
from different fields the possibility of
selecting their data sets
train us with a click and
automatically obtain a model ready to
make predictions without the need to
be an expert  in machine learning
in this way we can open the
potential of all these
technologies to millions
of developers throughout the
world
auto ml that is going to be the concept of
transferred learning and we can create
personalized models based on user data
using the  same models
from which google starts but pers
Analyzing for our clients' data
is natively integrated with a
great google cloud services solution
and we can even integrate it with
human tagging just for the
auto ml vision case which
greatly simplifies the application of this
technology to many other cases.  of use
also remember that here we pay
only for training the model and
then for each call we make to the
apis if we do not use the technology we do not
pay for it auto ml vision is the
first example of how we are
using this technology to
classify images based on the
collections of data from our
users using labeled data sets
we can with a click go on to
train a model that is ready to
put our applications into service
in a few minutes
we are going to discover this technology with
a demo to create our first
model we enter the graphical interface
of  auto ml vision there we can see a
summary of all the data s  ets and
collections that we have already imported
creating a new model is as simple
as clicking on the new data set button,
giving it a name
and uploading images from our hard
drive or pointing to a repository in the cloud
where we already have them labeled in
this case we are going to  reuse a model
that we have already trained
these data sets can be obtained from
many sources in the specific case that
we are going to use now we have downloaded
one from kagel
for this we have imported more than 4000
images of flowers with different
labels classifying our
flowers according to their variety
from the moment we have uploaded the
images the model is ready to
start its training first we can
take a look at the collection of
images we have to make sure
we have enough samples of
all the examples once we are
satisfied with our data set which
is  possible to check by looking
at the tag statistics and
making sure that all  all of them are
ahead of the threshold
we can pass the training stage
and make sure we have a model ready
to serve
just by clicking on this button
the magic of auto ml starts our
technology started to create a model
from scratch applying
learning technologies  transferred to our
pre-existing models
analyzing your data collection and in a
few minutes you will have a model ready
to serve
once the training has finished it is
possible to evaluate how it went and we can
see a complete evaluation where
we have the area under the curve the
precision and the  recall of our model
and even a confusion matrix that
tells us how likely we are
to label each of our labels incorrectly or correctly
if we are satisfied with our
training our app and it is
ready to serve we just have to go
to the prediction field
use a  test image
and make sure that the model
fits the prediction q  What we expect and in
fact we can even test
this model by putting in some
slightly more complex challenges of examples of something
that it was not quite ready to
identify
we see that here it is even
correctly identifying a drawing
when it has been trained with only
images
once  we want to start using this
model we have examples of how to call
the app and rest or how to call
the
model we just created from our python applications the
vision part there are many other
auto ml applications natural language analysis
translation and many other fields  they will
continue to benefit little by little from
this technology so that they can continue to
further expand their reach and democratize
artificial intelligence with google auto
ml is a solution that allows us to
extend the reach of all our
innovation start using auto ml on
guild cloud platform from  cloud dot
google.com free and created your first
model
no more